[Music]
we aren't supposed to be this far from
the palace Ariel getting old fins look
at this
you okay flounder sure you gotta show
him who's in charge
it's just scuttle
I want to be where the people are
I want to see you wanna see them dancing
you can't live in that world unless you
become a human yourself I don't know
life's full of tough choices amen
[Music]
guys look out
Disney's The Little Mermaid rated PGA in
theaters May 26th tickets on sale now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you broke the rules he went to the above
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans has to
stop I just want to know more about them
Mario don't
poor child I can help you you can't live
in that world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
watching you'll see me
someday I'll be
[Music]
he's a human you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
[Music]
when I first saw the original Little
Mermaid my whole world changed
[Music]
like so many of us little girls we all
just wanted to be mermaids
ferment is an iconic powerful story it
was important to expand and make it a
fuller experience this little mermaid
reflects what it means to want something
greater for yourself
that word now that's a voice Halle
Bailey when she sang for us it was so
emotional she set the bar and no one
ever surpassed it
I've been watching you for a long time
Melissa McCarthy as Ursula she's
extraordinary she's so dishy and
conniving we got a deal I might just
give you the premium package kid she's
hilarious and terrifying true
ears
The Little Mermaid was the first film I
ever scored it's especially emotional
coming back and with lin-manuel Miranda
who is so brilliant as long as we've
written expand what little mermaid is I
feel really proud to work on The Little
Mermaid because these characters live in
my heart
[Music]
know how but I know something's starting
right now
the world that Rob Marshall created
precious boundaries he's doing something
special
it's just a dream come true
[Music]
wish I could be
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]